hi
in this video i'm going to talk about
free radical scavenging system
so there are basically
two free radical scavenging system in
our body so one is enzyme dependent
scavenger of ross
that means reactive oxygen species
and another is non-enzymatic scavenger
of ross
so let's first talk about
enzyme-dependent scavenger of ross
so
first important enzyme that actually
scavenge rose is superoxide dismutase
and it performs this mutation of
superoxide
so in my previous video i have talked
about superoxide radicals which are
super duper dangerous actually the
super oxide radicals can damage dna
can peroxide lipids can cause lipid
peroxidation
it can also uh damage mitochondrial
membrane etc so these superoxide
radicals
have to be dismuted and have to be
converted into a less harmful
species
and superoxide dismutase actually
performs
that kind of function
and superoxide dismutase converts
the superoxide radicals into hydrogen
peroxide so hydrogen peroxide is also
harmful but less harmful than superoxide
so this harmful
hydrogen peroxide that is produced by
the activity of superoxide dismutase
also have to be cleaned up and also have
to be converted into
another harmless species
so
this h2o2 is converted to water
by the enzyme
glutathione peroxidase
so glutathione peroxidase actually break
peroxide and forms hydrogen peroxide
and forms
water
and oxygen
so glutathione peroxidase
actually reduce actually glutathione
peroxidase actually reduces these
hydrogen peroxide to water
so in this process and this particular
reaction is coupled with the oxidation
of reduced glutathione so reduced
glutathione is converted to oxidized
glutathione
and this is coupled with these
particular
reaction of conversion of hydrogen
peroxide to h2o
and what happens next
so for optimal function of glutathione
peroxidase
reduced glutathione is required so
reduce glutathione
pull inside a cell is
not
endless so what happens this glutathione
reduced glutathione pool have to be
regenerated and from oxidized
glutathione to reduce glutathione
this conversion is facilitated by
glutathione reductase so glutathione
reductase actually reduces oxidized
glutathione to reduce glutathione with
the help of nadph which in turn was
produced in the
pentose phosphate pathway that is why
pentose phosphate pathway in our body is
also very important
and apart from these glutam peroxidase
and glutathione reductase another
important enzyme is catalyst when the
amount of hydrogen peroxide
is high
then catalyze also
helps to convert h2o2
to
h2o that means peroxide to water and in
this respect sod
glutathione peroxidase glutathiones and
catalase
acts together to combat ross in a
in our cell so these are all enzymatic
scavenger of ross
now we would talk a bit about
non-enzymatic scavenger of ross
and we would see how
non-enzymatic scavenger of ross
functions inside our cell
so first non-enzymatic scavenger is
chelating agent such as edta so edta
actually chelates the ross
and
reduce its harmful effect apart from
edta there is vitamin e alpha tocopherol
so alpha tocopherol has a hydroxyl group
and say the alpha tocopherol can uh
break chains
of peroxides so let's say lipid
peroxidation already took place and this
alpha tocopherol has a hydrogen hydroxyl
group and now
it could react with that peroxidized
lipid
and it could form a alpha tocopherol
radical
and hydroxy peroxide radical would be
produced so this alpha tocopherol
radical
it's actually a free radical but it's
stable so it won't create another free
radical and it won't
evoke the chain reaction
in this way vitamin e acts as a very
efficient chain breaking antioxidant in
our tissues and help to help to protect
the polyunsaturated fatty acids of our
biomembrane apart from vitamin e vitamin
c which is available from all kind of
citrus fruit is also a very good
antioxidant
and vitamin a which is retinol which is
found in mainly carrots and other
sources also have to some extent
antioxidant activity
so with the help of enzyme scavengers
and non-enzymatic scavengers of ross our
body tries to combat with
react these harmful reactive oxygen
species and try to save our body
and i hope you enjoyed this video please
give it a quick thumbs up
and please subscribe
thank you